ihr kennt mich freunde ich bin nicht der
allerbeste fordert spieler rassistisch
war das ist nicht wahr das ist eine
sache von sekunden das ist das ist wow
wow cool ich liebe dieses spiel
aber ich glaube es gibt noch schlechtere
fordert spieler und zwar senioren cooles
bild gerade ich habe damals auch viele
videos von einer gruppe omas reagiert
die beispielsweise mannschaft gespielt
haben zurück und jetzt habe ich entdeckt
dass es nicht und diese gruppe von omas
gibt die gegen die zum ersten mal musik
hört oder zum ersten mal linken spiel
spielt sondern auch opas immer noch
tolles bild und wir reagieren heute auf
senioren spielen zum ersten mal vor's
neid griff die ak
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich brauche eigentlich gar nicht so
lange wie wir genauso scheiße in der tat
ein paar sekunden später am 2
[Musik]
diese gibt lustig wie die umgefallen
aber ich darf mich hier nicht zu
amüsieren freunde ich glaube meine omas
und opas werden noch schlechter da drin
theater minuten tanzt herum wie es gar
nicht tanzen so jetzt aber wieder nicht
später deutschland vorliegt warum läuft
denn ich vorwärts in der luft
berechtigte frage wenn ich in der luft
bin laufe ich auch immer vorwärts das
ist ganz schön windig da oben mich aufs
kind fallen und sagt dem blauen kinder
er ist mein absoluter favorite allein
wie er lacht es einfach so sympathisch
[Musik]
hammer aber wir schauen wir weiter sind
die leute du hast blaubeeren gegessen
wird es geht los
die leute du hast blaubär gegessen weil
gegen blau
du wirst bayerische bars ikone
das ist doch alles crew nämlich im baum
kommt doch mal hier raus musiker aus als
ob der von blumenkohl sitzt das sieht
eher aus als wenn der auf einem
blumenkohl sitzt wie kommen aber es
sieht wirklich so aus die hat er
eigentlich sein headset hier auf die
richtig wenn ich jetzt die maustaste
drücken
aber das war man das brauchen wir nicht
so viel schießen
das braucht man bei fordert nicht aus
wie ein klohäuschen dahin gesagt dass
wir holzen dahinten das ist so ein over
the hammer absoluter hammer er ist
glaube ich der beste von allen sein
headset ich krieg die krise so und jetzt
aber fliegen die pumpen hier der haut er
darin
vetter gar nichts runter noch ein stück
vorjahr
ja mach alles alles alles alles mein
absoluter favorit ist halt immer noch
der mit der brille der da gerade sitzt
nicht er hier mit seinem headset der ist
glaube ich herzen nicht so komplett
drauf der will nur im osten laufen aber
er ist auch in der zone dem spiel in
einer tonne könnte sprengstoff seien
vielleicht
in jeder tonne ist immer sprengstoffs
sind der feind wird edeka schießen soll
er fragt sich wo sage ich der feind den
ich erschieße muss und weg s-bahn zu
tanzen
wir haben wir jetzt aber wieder unseren
homie am start gleich wieder einbauen
kann
du musst jetzt mal zurückspringen mal
zurück ach was war denn das
[Musik]
das finde ich schon weg das geht sehr
schnell spielt mit mir jemand ja also er
wurde 49 sah und hat das auch erst einer
gewissen zeit geteilt aber ich hoffe
dass wir von dir noch einige runden mehr
sehen werden
du lieber gott was macht denn der oper
findet es erstaunlich also hätte nicht
gedacht dass man so weit schließen
können
bei mir ist es so wenn ich in fort meade
getötet werde vor dem sniper oder
irgendwas machen der rektor und bei ihm
ist es einfach das erstaunlich also
ähnlich gedacht dass man so weit
schießen können da es war nach vorne
wieder mal gucken oder als typ
prompt kommt das wird spannender kampf
nein
die limitierte platzzahl 30 uhr gibt es
eine jacke wie hose
ja herr m opa sie sind platz 35 geworden
dass new york die hose ja den heute aber
ja nicht gesehen dominiert hat den
konnte man gar nicht sehen vorhin was
machst du jetzt in athen absagen
geschossen werde ich werde ich zuerst
angeschossen warum baust du weiter da
sind keine sachen wurde schon wieder
angesetzt komm komm du wirst einfach tot
geprügelt junge goethe ihnen doch
geschlossen
auch hat er mich ja nicht so kalt wie
hundeschnauze
du hast einen fallschirm auf gemacht
hast mal zeigen wer herr auf der insel
[Musik]
ich zeig euch ja hier gerade nur
ausschnitte auf die ich reagiere ich
packe ich das ganze video natürlich nach
unten hin ich kenne die leute von
senioren zocker sind mega sympathische
leute zeigt die auf jeden fall marwa e
dieses fortnight video von den opas
sprich den kompletten körper schlüssel
dieser moment wenn jetzt jeder tönen
fordert ein schlüssel
nutzer sollen auf der jagd wird
unterhaltung
[Musik]
ja du da hat sich auf einmal eine
riesige grippewelle verbreitet bei den
ersten 30 leuten die weit hinten raus
gesprungen sind und dann waren halt alle
tot kern ja mal passieren und die sich
im ort genau hintertürchen krimi sehen
soll
habe ich im krimi gesehen stimmt es
jetzt her
ich bin glaube ich finde am tisch ende
europa ist total in rage wie läuft der
trend aber mal also er steht jetzt
hinter dem baum
er will was bauen lassen da gab gesagt
dhf tasten drücken dass man eine wand
hinsetzen oh mein gott erwählt
angeschossen wird angeschossen er wisse
auch nicht wo kommen denn hier
das ist auch warum konnte ich sehen wie
er auf seine tode reagiert ist einfach
legendär sind sie selbst spricht wie die
micky maus ich höre schüsse online wird
von der seite an
ich werde ja verrückt aber jetzt so
einem meter
der integrierte wird bin ich nur nicht
rot bist du noch nicht dass jetzt bist
du tot
auch jetzt ist alles was macht
eigentlich der mensch der sich da in
seinen komisches haus hinter der tür
wegen dem krimi versteckt hat wie sie
abgehauen bescheinigt er zuvor noch da
hätten
stimmt wenn die priener hütte ist bitte
einfach matschen com erkennen sind jetzt
freikommen ball direkt vor dem sturm wir
am boden auf seinen vertrag genau 14 die
erste tablette kann ruhig so weit kommen
preistipp siegprämie kleinen panzer oder
ja genau als siegprämie gibt es einen
kleinen party geht jetzt zur tür öffnet
die tür und wird sich jetzt in richtung
des kreises bewegen
erst hier schossen
ich fühle mit dir wer lieber herr ich
schieß auch immer zuerst und verpackt ja
wir ja nur ob ihr habt das richtig gut
gemacht
an der stelle wird das heutige wird
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich hab einfach bei mir
bei empfohlen gesehen hey die senioren
haben wir wieder ein video hochgeladen
und zwar diesmal wie die opas fordert
gespielt aber ich habe mir gedacht haben
muss ich darauf reagieren
cicek das komplette video aus freude ist
eine beschreibung unten verlegen will
ich in nächster zeit mal wieder mehr auf
videos von den senioren reagieren wie
beispielsweise auch wenn die zum ersten
mal eben die deutsch rap hören oder so
schreibt sie und in die kommentare
schaffen wir 60.000 likes freunde
das ist eine große zahl aber vielleicht
hat euch gefallen also mir das video auf
jeden fall sehr sehr spaß gemacht auch
zunehmend feucht und sonst würde ich an
der stelle ist einfach nur noch sagen
die 100